le ministre de l'intérieur charles
pasqua se descendent d'un quelconque
marchandage à propos des otages avec
l'iran et monsieur pasqua a réagi très
vivement aux accusations de la presse
anglo saxonne
après la libération des deux otages
français écoutez
j'ai déjà dit ce que j'avais à dire ont
versé aucune rançon et nous sommes
restés fidèles à nos principes et nous
n'avons aucune leçon à recevoir de ceux
qui ont vendu des armes et de ceux qui
éventuellement était prêt à payer des
rançons et l'opération de police menée
ce matin à auvers-sur-oise est-elle en
corrélation avec la libération des deux
otages français roger auque et jean
louis normandin ou bien est ce une
nouvelle étape vers la normalisation des
rapports entre la france et l'iran
ration de police entreprises ce matin
s'inscrit dans le cadre de la politique
que nous avons définies nous n'acceptons
pas et nous n'accepterons pas que sous
couvert de bénéficier de la protection
de nos lois certains utilisent ces
protections pour compléter ces personnes
étaient en situation irrégulière
régulière ou pas quand on se livre à des
activités qui sont contraires aux
intérêts de la république française et
aux règles internationales eh bien on en
subit les conséquences